GRACE TEO: In terms of
choosing our clients
there were a few criteria
that we were looking for.
Other then the fact that
they had a disability,
you had to have
been pretty stable,
so it wasn't going
to be fluctuating
too much over the semester.
And that is to make the design
constraints a little bit more
simple for the students.
Apart from a stable
disability, I
think what we loved
about the clients
this semester is
their motivation
to educate our students.
Having that intrinsic
quality of being an educator
was important for us.
They had to be able to
articulate their challenges
really well for the
students, and be
able to be patient
with the students,
because they're all learning
through this process.
And they might not
get the design process
right the first time.
But having clients
that were adventurous,
willing to try out new
things with the students,
that was very important.
The third piece was
purely logistical.
So, our students
are going to want
to interact with their
clients as many times as
possible over the semester, so
we made sure that they were all
accessible from MIT, I
think within a one hour
radius of MIT.
I think one thing you'll find
in a disability community
is that once you
talk to one person,
it's such a tight community
that word travels really fast.
So we had a little
bit of a lucky break
in that we contacted the
Cambridge Commission for People
with Disabilities,
and Kate Thurman there
helped us to send out an
email to the entire community
of people with disabilities.
And then I'm pretty sure we got
about 50 emails, if not more,
from people who were
interested in being clients.
And so we either tried to
talk to them over the phone
or visit them in person
to get to know them.
WILLIAM LI: I think, to
be very honest though,
in terms of having clients
involved in the class--
participating in lectures
and some of the labs,
and also certainly being very
much a part of the design
process-- to be very honest
it's a tricky decision,
and something that we decided
to try this year sort of to see
what would happen.
I think a big part
of it is really
the user-centered or
participatory design
nature of the class
that we really
want students to understand
the person that they're
working with.
Understand their challenges, and
realities, in all the contexts
that they're in, in
their home, or when
they're out in Boston,
or even at MIT as well.
So I think one big part of it
was to really give students
the opportunity to interact
more with their clients,
and really get their feedback
quickly, and work on the design
process together.
I think the other
part is we really
tried to see our
clients as collaborators
with the students.
As Grace mentioned,
really, I think
clients are most attuned
to their own needs,
and their own ideas.
Or their own needs in terms
of what assistive technologies
might be useful.
So they really are
able to give kind
of the best possible feedback.
So having them [? embedded, ?]
or participating in the class,
I think was really important
and really a valuable experiment
or experience to try.
GRACE TEO: William
is exactly right.
It was an experiment this year.
We had lab assistants
in the class this year
who were students last
year, and they did not
have clients in their class.
And when we first
made a decision
to say OK, clients
can be in our class,
and our lab assistants
saw how that was going,
they raised quite
a few concerns.
By the end of the
day we said, you
know what, our
students just need
to learn how to negotiate
these situations.
It's part of the
learning process.
It's an important thing
to be able to work around
these kinds of situations.
And that's fine.
The other thing
that I don't like
is when we talk
about disability,
or we teach students how
to talk about disability,
as if people with
disabilities are
this outside group
that we are kind
of observing from the inside.
I think it's a much more
inclusive way of teaching
if we can bring in
people with disabilities
to talk about their own
experiences with the students.
Instead of us just
showing slides and saying,
these are the terms
that you should
use when you're talking to
people with disabilities.
It means so much more
coming from the people
with disabilities themselves.
In terms of how we set up
the students and the clients
and coordinated that
interaction-- so let
me start right
from the beginning.
We meet with the clients.
Once we know we've
selected them,
I believe we selected
about 15 clients
at the start of the class.
And we told them,
there is a potential
that you will get to work
with students this semester,
and this is the
expectation, that you
are able to give two to
three hours each week
to meet with our students
from this date to this date.
Then we went to our
students and gave them
a whole list of the clients.
And we didn't
describe the clients
in too much detail other than
some potential challenges
that they had that students
might want to work on.
Then we let the students
decide for themselves
which clients they were
interested in working with.
Based on their skill sets,
and based on their interests,
we meshed up students
with the clients.
And so at the end
of it, we actually
only had 11 student teams and
so 11 clients that were matched.
So we had to tell the remaining
four clients, I'm sorry,
you were not matched
for this semester,
but we really appreciate
your availability.
So right after we finished
that matching, we basically
sent an email to the clients and
the students, introduced them,
told them this is how you
can contact each other.
And then for the very
first client meeting
for the students, their mentors
went along with the students
to just make sure the
interaction went well.
Something that Seth,
Professor Teller, established
in the class probably
from the first year or so,
was the student client contract,
where the student will say,
we are going to work with
you as well as we can,
these are the expectations
that you can hold us to.
And then the clients
also have expectations
that the students
can hold them to,
and they both sign off for that.
And it's just a
way of facilitating
that initial interaction
so that both sides are
able to talk about what
they will be able to do,
and what they won't
be able to do.
And managing those
expectations is a huge part
of any kind of relationship.
WILLIAM LI: Yeah, this
contract, and really setting
the expectations.
Setting the stage for
students to succeed,
and clients to really understand
what the process is about
and how they can be most
valuable to the students
in terms of giving feedback
and sharing their ideas openly,
and really knowing
that they're kind
of an equal partner in the
team's project is really key.
I think Grace did
a lot of great work
this year in terms
of the curation part.
We had a chance to talk to
a lot of potential clients,
and really figure
out what would be
the best match for the
expected makeup of students
in our class.
As grace mentioned,
clients who are
adventurous, and
interested in learning,
and interested in
teaching, and open minded,
have some assistive
technology idea in mind.
I think this is a big part, the
front part of the class that
can be really valuable
to help set it up
for success for the semester.